- N'oubliez pas une chose,
c'est que la vraie inspiratrice,
tetetetetetetetetetetetetetetetu
sur la table, vous n'avez rien.
Il fauyeyeyer.
- Louis-Ferdinand Céline est
un écrivain mythique du XXième
siècle, et la légende voulait
qu'il se soit fait voler
plusieurs manuscrits. Ils ont
été retrouvés près de 60 ans
après sa mort.
ALBAN CERISIER, conservation des
fonds patrimoniaux, Gallimar
- C'est une histoire magique,
enfin, voilà, dont on rêverait
tous de... de vivre d'autres
épisodes.
- La disparition de 5324
feuillets remonte à juin 1944.
L'auteur du chef-d'oeuvre
"Voyage au bout de la nuit"
avait fui Paris à la libération
parce qu'il craignait d'être
jugé pour ses propos antisémites
et collaborationnistes.
Son appartement de la rue
Girardon avait été pillé,
et jusqu'à la fin de sa vie,
l'écrivain dira qu'il s'était
fait voler.
- On m'a tout volé,
'a'a'a'a tout pris.
- On se disait toujours :
quelle est la part de vrai,
quelle est la part de faux
làs?s?s?s? Est-ce que
c'est encore une provocation
de Céline? Voilà.
Non, la vérité, c'est qu'il
disait vrai. Il disait vrai.
- Les manuscrits cachés avaient
été remis au début des années
2000 à un critique du journal
"Libération" avec promesse de
ne rien dévoiler avant la mort
de Lucette Destouc
la veuve de Céline.
À la mort de celle-ci en 2019,
le critique révèle l'existence
des feuillets. Les Céliniens,
dont Bernabé Wesley, jubilent.
BERNABÉ WESLEY, codirecteur,
Relire Voyage au bout de la nuit
- C'est un événement inouï
et sans précèdent
dans l'histoire littéraire.
Aujourd'hui, on parle d'un mètre
cube de manuscrits, et ce ne
sont pas des manuscrits de fond
de tiroirs, des lettre
ou des choses déjà publiées.
- Le livre "Guerre",
écrit probablement en 1934,
est le premier livre à être tiré
de cette découverte.
Il est la pièce manquante entre
les romans "Voyage au bout
de la nuit" et "Mort à crédit".
Une révélation pour BIZ,
admirateur de l'oeuvre.
BIZ, écrivain et admirateur
de Louis-Ferdinand Céline
- C'est comme un fan des Beatles
qui découvrirait un nouvel album
des Beatles. C'est aussi
important. Il nous raconte
l'horreur de la guerre, il y a
des passages magnifiques où
il dénonce... il dit d'ailleurs,
il commence le livre avec ça :
"J'en enfermé la guerre
dans ma tête",
il a reçu d'explosions...
Il aura gardé toute sa vie
des acouphènes, qui l'auront
rendu fou, lit,,,,,,
empêcher de dormir.
- Le plus grand écrivain
du monde, c'est
Louis-Ferdinand Céli
- Des écrivains comme
Jack Kerouac et Réjean Ducharme
ont été de grands lecteurs
de Louis-Ferdinand Céline.
Mais l'homme derrière l'écriv
divise le public, car il a tenu,
dans des pamphlets, des propos
antisémites inexcusables.
- Je vais toute ma viei i i i i,
ce qu'il a fait, jamais excuser
toutes ces horreurs antisémites
infondées.s.s.s.s.s.s.
Mais, par contre,
je suis capable de reconnaître
le plaisir qu'il m
quand je le lis.
- Dans ce roman qui vient
de i i i i i i il n'y absolument
aucune mention des Juifs.
- Ce qui compte,
c'est l'objet...
- "Guerre" s'est écoulé
à près de 200 000 exemplaires
en France. Gallimard compte
publier trois autres livres
à partir des feuillets
retrouvés. Au Ci
des Longs Réages, à Meudon,
l'écrivain et médecin
Louis-Ferdinand Céline doit
se retourner dans sa tombe,
lui  l l l l l l l la lourdeur
de l'homme.
- Nous verrons peut-être un jout
contre... contre le poids,
mais c'est pas pour demain.
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal